hä aber metallic Christmas jetzt the
best time of you
[Musik]
absolut perfekt die Gäste können kommen
das Essen vom Lieferservice war eine
super Idee von dir der spare ich mir
komplett diese lästige Kocherei
zum Glück
nur irgendwas fehlt nur was
kein küchengestank keine keine Spuren
von der Arbeit kein Fettgeruch keine
Spritzer keine Zwiebel Finger da weiß ja
jeder gleitet von mir ich glaube ich
habe da was das neue Raumspray
haushaltsgerüche von muchtel in den vier
Duftsorten Zwiebeln
Rindsuppe und angebranntes
jetzt in der Weihnachtsmann der Edition
Blaukraut Kartoffelknödel und ganz
haushaltsgerüche von muchtel damit
riecht wie selbst gekocht jetzt brauchen
Sie nur noch ein glaubhaftes Outfit so
und jetzt können die Gäste kommen
haushaltsgerüche von muchtel für einen
gelungenen Abend